GAME SINCE VALENTINES GAME WHEN.
HE PUT
THE
NYLANDER.
HERE'S HOLL A A
FIVE GOALS THIS SEASON AGAINST
HE MENTIONED THE LEAFS ARE THE E
ONE OFF THE BEST FACE-OFF TEAM
IN THE LEAGUE.
THE REDCORED!
OH, IT FOUND ITS WAY PAST
>> Mickey: THIS IS JUST LIKE AAY
LEAGUE.
MARNER SCORES AGAIN. OFS IT.
KNOCAMPBELL.
GAGNER THREW IT IN
HIS 37th.
AND HISWINGS THIRD GOAL TONIGHT5
SHOT OR NOT. FUNNY.
AND HRONEK SHOT THE PUCK
7-4. SETTLE THIS
THING DOWN.
THERE'S A BEAUTIFUL DEFLECTION ?
IF NOT, IT WILL BE 8-6, BUT
WE'LL
HE WAS FLYING. FROM MIKHEYEV
CERTAINLY HURTS.
HERE THE
[HORN]
>> Kenny: RAYMOND WITH HIS
SECOND OF THE NIGHT!R.
>> Kenny: A BELLTOWER POWER PLAY
AND CHANCE TO TIE THE GAME.
GOES OVER THE STICK A DETROIT.
>> Micke
STAAL KEEPS POSSESSION.
GOAL AND HIS SIXTH POINT OF